[Musique]
bienvenue pour ce nouvel entretien
politique sur tv 78 nous poursuivons
chaque semaine nos échanges avec les
maires du département des yvelines
invité aujourd'hui eddie aït à la tête
de carrières sous poissy depuis juillet
dernier mais aussi depuis entre 2008
pardon et 2014
bonjour à vous bonjour carrières sous
poissy commune de plus de 16 mille
habitants elle se trouve dans la sixième
circonscription à partir à
l'intercommunalité de grand paris seine
et oise et la première actualité et déjà
de votre commune c'est une réflexion qui
est en cours autour de la tristement
célèbre mr des déchets cette montagne de
détritus de 300 hectares à cheval
également sur les communes de triel sur
seine de chanteloup les vignes et qui va
disparaître grâce aux actions notamment
du département se pose maintenant la
question de l'avenir de ce site qu'elles
sont déjà vos souhaits pour cette
ancienne on va dire mer de déchets mon
premier souhait était de garantir une
réappropriation par les citoyens de ce
que pourrait être l'avenir de ce grand
espace naturel qui a été souillé comme
vous l'avez rappelé par une décharge
sauvage tristement appelé la mère des
déchets et qui a trop fait justement la
une des médias et les caries roy était
dans la tente une réhabilitation de
l'image de leur commune et je crois que
ce travail de prospective et de
concertation que nous engageons avec la
commission extra municipale sur l'avenir
de la plaine va apporter des réponses
nous on souhaite tout d'abord un conte
de redonner la parole aux habitants sur
l'avenir de cette plaine c'est chose
faite avec cet outil qu à d'ailleurs été
présenté à l'ensemble des parties
prenantes soient le département la
région où l'intercommunalité c'est aussi
pour nous l'occasion de réaffirmer ce
que nous avons dit devant les les caries
roi pendant la campagne électorale c'est
que nous souhaitons un projet
l'opportunité écologique hors du commun
mais surtout inclusif et créateurs
d'emplois
nous avons besoin d'un secteur crée de
l'emploi au regard de la main d'oeuvre
jeune que nous avons sur le territoire
et qu'il est aujourd'hui formé est mis
sur le chemin de l'enfant cette question
environnementale plus largement c'est le
dossier primordial un petit peu de votre
nouvelle mandature vous avez aussi
déposé une plainte contre x pour mise en
danger de la vie d'autrui en raison de
présence de métaux lourds
des cons avec forte concentration dans
certains sols nous souhaitons faire de
l'écologie très clairement la grande
cause de ce mandat
mais une fois qu'on a dit ça on n'a rien
dit donc il faut faire la preuve que
nous sommes capables collectivités
territoriales d'intervenir pour protéger
les habitants on peut les protéger sur
le plan social sur le plan économique
mais on doit aussi les protéger des
risques environnementaux et donc nous
avons fait le choix en plus de lancer
une démarche de concertation sur la
plaine d'avoir une démarche juridique et
même judiciaire concernant la pollution
aux métaux lourds de cette plaine savait
que les taux sont très largement
supérieurs aux moyennes franciliennes
qu'il ya eu des cas de saturnisme qui a
encore des risques d'intoxication au
plomb aujourd'hui de nos populations
donc on a souhaité marquer une étape en
faisant la démonstration que la ville
était capable de créer un bouclier
juridique
voilà donc là nous protégeons sur une
des idées des pollutions qui caractérise
les les salles de carrières sous poissy
c'est une démarche un peu nouvelle pour
une pour une commune comme comme la
nôtre mais on l'a souhaité très clair et
très transparente et puis c'est surtout
la volonté de montrer qu'on tourne une
page sur un certain laisser faire voilà
donc on a la volonté de dire à nos
habitants nous allons vous protéger
sur l'ensemble des risques
environnementaux auxquels vous pouvez de
confronter est ce qu'on pourra
identifier les pollueurs finalement
bahia l'histoire qui nous explique les
raisons de cette pollution
c'est pour ça que nous avons fait une
plainte contre x on souhaite que le
procureur de la république puisse
diligenter une enquête et déterminer les
responsabilités
ce qu'on souhaite surtout nous c'est
faire reconnaître le préjudice
écologique et l'évaluation du coût de ce
préjudice écologique ce qui nous
intéresse très clairement c'est obtenir
la réparation est donc une indemnisation
significative permettant tout ou partie
de la dépollution des sols car nous
avons besoin même si les projets peuvent
être multiples sur cette plaine le
département propose une forêt ça mérite
d'être étudié néanmoins nous pouvons
aussi travailler sur la problématique de
la résilience alimentaires comment faire
que cette plaine agricole renoue avec
son histoire justement agricoles et donc
en dépolluant tout ou partie de ces
espaces nous pouvons permettre à cette
plaine de renouer avec une forme
d'agriculture périurbaines qui en
période de crise sanitaire est plus
qu'utile parce qu'on a vu à quel point
la rupture
des chaînes d'approvisionnement ont été
réels quand la machine économique se
bloque
je traite la notion de résilience
alimentaire vous parler de cette
question de crise sanitaire justement
dans l'actualité ce n'est pas propre à
votre commune de carrières sous poissy
mais à la gestion de ce dossier de cette
crise sanitaire il ya aussi la gestion
sécuritaire avec la menace d'attentats
et le plan vigipirate qui a été encore
renforcée qu'il faut mettre en pratique
maintenant dans les différentes communes
comment s'est passée plus globalement la
rentrée c'était la rentrée pour les
élèves cette semaine ont très très
particulière j'imagine que vous vous
êtes rendus dans les établissements
scolaires aussi très rapidement vous
dire que depuis le mois de juillet que
tous les maires sont installés on vit
quand même une époque très très
particulière crise économique crise
sanitaire crise terroristes ça vous
montre à quel point notre démocratie
elle est solide néanmoins et à quel
point la commune échelons de base de la
nation est indispensable au
fonctionnement de notre république
alors j'en profite aussi pour saluer
vous permettez wifi tous les services de
l'état qui travaillent à nos côtés parce
que la période elle est très difficile
pour tout et pour tout c'est une pensée
pour tous les citoyens qui sont
confrontés à la crise
alors oui je me suis rendu dans les
écoles mais aussi dans les accueils de
loisirs hier pour témoigner notre
reconnaissance au jazz aux agents
publics qui sont mobilisés et aux
enseignants car effectivement l'alertent
attentats qui est l'allergie peyrat qui
est porté à son maximum
aujourd'hui suscite des inquiétudes
elles sont légitimes il a fallu assurer
la présence de la police municipale
vérifier tout ce qui est centrale
d'alarmé
tout ce qui est dispositif d' alerte
mecque du barriérage fléché des entrées
différents membres
tout ça je dirais la fonction publique
elle est au coeur de cette réaction les
élus ils sont là pour être totalement
mobilité ce sont des choses que nous
savons faire
néanmoins ce qui m'inquiète aujourd'hui
à travers cette triple crise que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
économique sanitaire et terroristes et
l'absence de cap qui en découle est ce
que sacré comme comme trouble chez nos
concitoyens et c'est chez chacune et
chacun d'entre nous
quand pourrons nous trouver une
perspective positive et quand pourrons
nous retrouver un cours normal de notre
riche pas que les gens attendent cela et
ça c'est la vision du politique on doit
leur garantir à l'échelon du département
de la ville de la région mais aussi du
gouvernement
moi si j'ai un message à leur faire
passer aujourd'hui c'est donnez nous une
perspective on sache où nous devons
aller avec nos populations carouge
puis les attendent de savoir si une
issue est possible et je crois que là il
ya une vraie inquiétude
il faut tout faire pour que la
perspective soit redonné pour éviter que
le délitement social se renforce et
s'accentue encore davantage le croyait
des décisions qui sont prises au niveau
du gouvernement dans ce temps on entend
aussi certains maires monter un petit
peu de au créneau et monte le ton sur la
question des commerces de proximité par
exemple certains de vos confrères mer on
demandait la réouverture des commerces
alors que le gouvernement avait dit ces
commerces ne seront pas ouverts vous
faites partie de ces merdes déjà qui
demandent la réouverture des commerces
de proximité
moi j'étais j'ai essayé d'être très
courtois sur la façon dont l'information
nous est annoncée et présentée on peut
dire qu'il ya quand même une marge de
progression à faire de la part du
gouvernement et des services de l'état
là dessus nous sommes le premier maillot
on est sur le front et on est
véritablement les derniers informés
d'une façon officielle donc un petit
sujet sur la construction de la décision
avec nous voilà on apprend là comme ça
au débotté qu'un couvre-feu sera peut
être réinstaurée tout à l'heure en ile
de france
aucune concertation aucune annonce
préalable alors qu'il ya quelques jours
on nous annonce qu'il est terminé
c'est un exemple néanmoins je fais
partie de ces mères qui exprime un oui
de colère c'est à dire on va faire nous
restons pas prendre de responsabilité
mais on est un peu en colère sur la
façon dont les choses nous annoncer et
concernant les commerces de proximité
je fais pas partie de ceux qui ont pris
des arrêtés municipaux parce qu'une
façon déjà sont illégales
ils sont illégaux excusez moi et ensuite
on ne joue pas comme ça avec la santé
financière d'un commerçant disant vous
avez vous pu réouvrir vous allez vous
prendre une amende et c'est moi j'ai
signé l'appel de l'association des
maires d'ile-de-france dont je suis
membre du conseil d'administration au
titre de millions des maires des
yvelines pour dire que l'état devait
mettre en place une clause de revoyure
et devrait très clairement étudier la
situation pour permettre un maximum de
réouverture possible mais je n'irai pas
à signer des arrêtés municipaux qui sont
illégaux qui seront déférés en justice
et casser ensuite par l'autorité
préfectorale ça n'a pas de sens pour moi
d'aller vers une démarche poujadiste
voilà moi je souhaite qu'on ait un cadre
responsable parce que laver et la
réalité c'est que les gens sont dehors
aujourd'hui pour beaucoup sans
protection pour beaucoup ne comprenons
plus les injonctions contradictoires qui
leur sont faites
et c'est normal puisqu'elles sont
contradictoires donc moi j'ai besoin
qu'on ait une ligne claire
un discours de responsabilité on
n'enraye l'épidémie il s'agit pas
simplement de ralentir son à
l'accélération
il faut qu'on lutte durablement contre
l'épidémie il faut voir les messages de
l' agence régionale de santé
ils sont catastrophiques en termes
d'occupation des des places dans les
hôpitaux en réanimation
je crois que ça c'est un indicateur qui
doit nous alerter nous faire prendre
conscience que nous a dit j sont pas
collectivement de façon responsable
aujourd'hui donc plus de fermeté
peut-être vers un continent pourquoi
surtout un discours d'autorité partager
compris la gestion de crise et une
personne qui parle un message une
orientation
on peut pas continuer comme comme c'est
aujourd'hui voilà quelques mots de
politique vraiment politicienne à
présent pour finir cette séquence
d'entretien vous êtes aussi conseiller
régional vous avez été élus sur ce
mandat sur la liste de claude bartolone
avec la gauche les écologistes est ce
que vous serez à nouveau candidat
l'année prochaine si les élections bien
évidemment été maintenu
alors j'ai déjà la chance d'être élu à
la région depuis 2004 qui est un très
très beau mandat au regard des
compétences
j'ai connu la majorité je connus
l'opposition avec jean paul huchon puis
aujourd'hui valérie pécresse je préside
un groupe écologiste et progressistes à
la région 11 élus c'est une force
centrale dans l'opposition aujourd'hui
aux côtés de léo groupe
j'ai la ferme intention de pouvoir me
représenter aux élections régionales si
j'en ai bien évidemment l'opportunité
sur un projet sur une rencontre
j'ai pu échanger avec audrey pulvar avec
a lancé un appel ça paye ile-de-france
en commun j'ai vu une femme de
conviction qu'avec la volonté d'ancrer
son action sur la grande couronne auprès
des élus locaux moi c'est le cadre dans
lequel j'invite audrey pulvar a
travaillé aux côtés des élus locaux et a
bien agir en lien avec la grande
couronne paris ces deux milieux dhabi
deux millions d'habitants
le reste de l'ile-de-france et 10
millions d'habitants donc je crois qu'il
de france a est une est une merveilleuse
endormi qui mérite d'être un peu plus
bousculé d'être davantage au service des
franciliennes et des frontières donc
j'ai envie de pouvoir avoir un nouveau
mandat là dessus pour appuyer l'action
territoriale aussi dans les îles les
forces de gauche peuvent s'unir
parce qu'aujourd'hui elles sont divisées
et puis il faudra choisir quelqu'un pour
l'incarner vous avez évoqué audrey
pulvar notamment moi j'ai signé son
appel donc je ne vais pas vous parler
des autres évidemment que évidemment que
l'union
l'union est plus que nécessaire je vaux
cible aussi il ya quand même des
divergences de fond sur certains
dossiers sur la vision pour l'île de
france
on évoque la possibilité d'un report des
élections peut-être que ça peut ouvrir
un temps complémentaire de réflexion et
de travail en commun néanmoins des
projets co construit avec des électorats
différents ils s'additionneront ils
créeront une dynamique
ce qu'il faut c'est s'adresser d'abord
et avant tout aux franciliennes et aux
franciliens qui attendent de nous une
offre politique nouvelle construite et
en phase avec leurs préoccupations et
surtout en capacité à apporter des
réponses à la triple crise que
j'évoquais encore et vous excusez moi de
le répéter crise économique crise
sanitaire écrit ce terroriste les gens
souffrent aujourd'hui nous devons les
accompagner
on les protège est ce le rôle des élus
et c'est maintenant notre démocratie est
mise à l'épreuve
merci beaucoup et dia était d'avoir été
avec nous pour cet entretien politique à
revoir dès à présent en replay sur notre
site internet et puis on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine avec un nouvel élu du
département et blé noir à bientôt
[Musique]